il ya deux sortes d'homosexuels,
il y a ceux qui sont malades
effectivement ça pour de l'argent
frédéric mitterrand cet hiver
la maladie l'avait vue auparavant les
sens
comprenez-vous les mêmes éléments
comment jugez-vous les hommes qui aiment
les hommes
le but c'est pas normal c'est un risque
la réplique à adam la maison il ya un
mois
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai je me pose
la question si c'est exact
dans les faits les plus belles femmes
comme les calmants
faut pas s'étonner que je descendais
plus tard
c'est positif
kompany le floréal an
plusieurs mois
quand on regarde pas
que faire après
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des vélos
ces départs
tu vois je vois les auditeurs
franchement vol
suite
qui
vite
plus petit
et quelquefois même droit pour tous
chaque soir
sur le sexe l'orientation
c'est le droit de pouvoir se marier
pour les cours
dès l'engagement 31 de la campagne
présidentielle de françois hollande
et l'une des priorités du début de son
quinquennat
après les pays-bas la belgique
l'espagne ou encore le danemark la
france tente par des mariages
homosexuels
une réforme emblématique pour la
gauche mais rejetée par une majorité
de la droite
les aménageurs et jean piat michel
dault rapporteur du texte il ya treize
ans que cet élu socialiste a déjà
été le rapporteur de la loi sur le
pacs
l'om
cet ancien magistrat s'est toujours
battu pour les droits des homosexuels
plusieurs mois une présentation pour
l'égalité donc c'est bien
l'égalité n'est pas
à avec israël
que tous ne sont pas tous égaux
parce que debbie sont pas de la même
manière
parce que nous avons
des familles
lépine permettent de faire du site du
lieu
dissimulés dans des milieux différents
nous ne sommes pas divorcés
mais je pense que le rôle du
législateur
et notamment que c'est le rôle de la
socialiste
je prends toute la mesure
possible
pour réduire les inégalités
le prix d'une
m
le collectif la même pour tous
convoqué par claude léger et
médiatique
il faisait défaut
cet humoriste atypique chroniqueuse
mondaine et fervente catholique
belga la porte-parole des opposants au
texte
13 janvier 2013
julien et cécile manifeste pour la
première fois de leur vie
comme il l'avait fait bien
au travers
fauvergue
membre d'alliance guitare une
association fondée par christine boutin
contre l'avortement et l'euthanasie
ils sont opposés au projet du
gouvernement
très bien merci à la madeleine
cécile est conseillère municipale à
fontenay-le-fleury dans les dix villes
ceux qui la gêne dans ce projet de loi
mais l'adoption par les couples
homosexuels
les couleurs et un papa et maman va
ordonner de barbara bush de maman
et ça me semble 4 les dix ans profond
de l'enfant qui a besoin de s'identifier
à un père le maire
ce jour-là le champ-de-mars occultant
avec des drapeaux bleus
une bataille de chiffres a opposé les
anti mariage homosexuel au gouvernement
entre 340 milles selon la préfecture de
police
les huit cent mille manifestants selon
les organisateurs ou peut-être
comptabilité -avi
face à cette opposition qui s'exprime
de plus en plus forte
les partisans du projet de loi à
descendre dans la rue à leur tour
au delà du mariage gay ferait bien de
france qui vont apparaître et deux
conceptions de la famille qui vont
s'affronter
auckland
gary roberts
autre regret on va voir
c'est la première fois qu'on manifeste
il a été suivi par quelques semaines
et pourtant personne dans les victimes
et de blessés contre notre liberté
notre mais il est possible de passer
cette semaine cela dit d'après lui
à l'assemblée nationale les députés
ont commencé mardi l'examen du texte
l'opposition entend créer le débat
dans l'hémicycle
cinq mille amendements seront déposés
le projet de loi prévoit le mariage et
l'adoption pour les couples homosexuels
mais il n'est pas question d'autoriser
la procréation médicalement t'assister
la gestation pour autrui pourtant les
chiffons rouges tabagique et la droite
pendant les cent dix heures de
discussion dans l'hémicycle j
à l'article 16h20 civile
cléopâtre et le problème
israélo-palestinien entr les mecs il
affirmé formellement ici
ce gouvernement
s'est déjà prononcée
et confirme
il est asolument opposés à l'assiette
les gares
au final
les débats vont révéler le karité et
la détermination de christiane taubira
après des jours et des nuits passées
dans l'hémicycle
merci à tous pour ses jours et ses
nuits passées ensemble
pour eux
c'est
or ces sourires penser à l'avenir
pendant cette augmentation aussi envie
de 6 ans entre conviction
ce projet de loi woods n'a conduit ap
lancée autrui
à quoi ressemblera la bactérie
pensez aux truites dizaine annuelle des
vinasses
relève de l'irréductible inquiétude
pour l'autre c'est ce que nous avons
fait tout le long de ce débat
après l'assemblée nationale c'est au
tour du sénat de toscane le sénat âge
choisi de prendre son temps et
d'entendre toutes les opinions sont
acceptées
quarante éditions menée par
jean-pierre michel et jean-pierre sueur
le président de la commission des lois
les éditions qui vont permettre aux
sénateurs de se faire leur propre
opinion
la plupart des sénateurs en tout cas il
faut le préserver t
qui est dépendante de l'augmentation de
leur parti politique
pourquoi mais comment peut-on les
acteurs on ne peut plus
pour certains ça me paraît beaucoup
plus nuancée
les groupes en ce que
avec des informations pour le comme ses
collègues hier aux condors ont pour but
que de mal le terrain
peut-être que certains sénateurs
pourraient %
le le choix d'un côté comme de l'autre
le surtout je pense que ceux qui sont
contre par principe
pour se détacher de son concurrent
précité arriver à une abstention
record
il devait être plus positif dans les
débats anthropologue et sociologue
psychiatre religieux juriste et membre
de la société civile
on se succéder à la tribune pendant
plusieurs semaines
très vite il apparaît que ce n'est pas
tant le mariage qui fait débat mais
plutôt la question de l'adoption par
des couples homosexuels très bien quand
même
la première
au québec peu après
trompés le sénat va voter mon rôle
très particulier
autant que dans la capacité du corps à
démêler cette caisse et malentendus
sur la filiation
on comprend mieux après après deux
trois mois de débats qu'on ne les
comprenaient au début
donc j'attends beaucoup du sénat jeudi
c'est une assemblée dont je sais que
depuis longtemps
que c'est un endroit où on débat des
questions vraiment au fond
alors pour montrer à quel point cette
question fait débat
je citerai parmi les très nombreux
l'ema les très nombreuses personnes
j'aurais pu citer un organisme qui est
tout à fait capital union nationale des
associations familiales qui dans un
document qu'elle a rendus le public en
octobre un diction 6
ouvrir l'ensemble de l'adoption aux
couples de même sexe pose en
particulier la question de l'adoption
plénière
alors qu'un enfant ne pénètre coda
nommé d'une femme l'axé éventuelle
adoption plénière remettrait
juridiquement cause cette réalité
laissant croire qu'il est possible de
naître de deux personnes de même sexe
j'ai cité ce texte pour montrer et
dénoncer désigner un malentendu car
bien entendu personne parmi les
défenseurs du projet inimaginable 2
laisser croire qu'un enfant peut naître
de ces deux femmes ou de deux hommes ap
et qu'il n'est pas question à travers
l'adoption plénière de remettre on
peut juridiquement en cause cette
réalité
si les pédopsychiatres l'adoption par
des couples de même sexe fait débat
un enfant peut-il être aidé par deux
parents de même sexe
les avis divergent j
ceux-ci pourront danser
de sorte débutée il faut savoir que
pour un enfant serait strictement rien
dire
un parent de même sexe deuxièmement
pour un enfant un père qui ne leur
mentent gendre pas une mère qui
n'engendre pas
soit d'un point de vue réelle soit d'un
point de vue symbolique comme on l'a vu
dans l'adoption de la mp
là ça ne peut pas fonctionner
parce qu'un enfant ne peut pas se dire
de deux hommes outre deux femmes
le coupable est de 2
l'absolue nécessité d'avoir le père
qui une messe ça me surprend de la part
un psychanalyste à ce que
% est-ce que c'est pas plus important
d'avoir une fonction paternelle et une
fonction maternelle
l'équipe de départ forcément assumer
le parquet le cas du sexe masculin pour
la fonction paternelle et pour un tarif
parfois rien si tu te fais un mois jeu
je suis un père qui fait beaucoup de
fonction maternelle
le paternel
de la femme ne sera jamais le même que
le paternel de l'homme le maternel de
l'homme sera jamais le même que le
maternel de la femme
c'est à dire que au delà de cette
fonction
les quelque chose qui dépasse ces
fonctions-là killer lettres propres
du père et notre propre de la mère et
là on a vu
que l'enfant différencie cela tout
simplement parce que oui un père ne
sera jamais une mère comme les autres
et que les que ceux que cela dépasse
l'histoire de la fonction le fait de
descendre les poubelles et faire la
vaisselle cela n'a rien à voir
il ya des situations concrètes estimant
que la situation concrète c'est parce
qu'il est possible est pensable
que dans notre société un enfant qui
soit et l'elysée
par qui que ce soit n'est pas
référencé aux deux sexes qui existent
dans la société
pour ça il me semble que tenir un tel
discours c est dire non ils n'auraient
pas la chance c'est absolument action
est-ce que le concours si d'hercule
cette référence aux deux sexes est-ce
qu'elle doit être dans le cas de la
famille nucléaire
ou alors à ce qu'elle fait de façon
plus énergique c'est ça la question
pragmatique qu'il faut se poser
%
de se concevoir de façon tout à fait
il affiche
e combien d'entre nous ici
e
on compte une idée de leurs familles
qui ne se résignent pas uniquement à
leur père à leur mère
si les juristes le débat est tout aussi
animée
certains pensent que la loi remettant en
cause le droit de la filiation et la
base même du droit civil
d'autres pensent au contraire que la loi
doit suivre les évolutions de la
société
la question qui se joue ici c'est la
question des liens de droit et puis
parce que la régate familiaux
qui sont fondés sur deux heures à
porte de rapports qui sent le rapport de
deux mois il ya un an ce qui repose sur
le mariage et l affiliation c'est à
dire
le rapport de logique
c'est que je voulais dire c'est que ces
liens de la filiation et des mariages
ils sortent pas détachable départ
donc ici voilà
mis en avant le lien biologique la
vérité biologique
et vous accordez le mariage aux couples
homosexuels qui ont défilé à 6 ans
qui seront forcément fictives puisqu'il
ne prend très pas entre eux
bouleversée à ce point
tous le droit de la filiation
parce que vous accordez le mariage à
des couples homosexuels
qui n'a pas en tout cas même pas
une majorité de français
je pense que c'est extrêmement grave et
pour moi si vous le faites prenez le
temps et réfléchissez en même temps
vous pouvez pas dissocier
on verra plus tard ce qu'on a mis sous
le tapis pour le réduire ça
franchement je suis venu vous dire mais
a fait passer c'est trop rare
j'ai un peu le sentiment que c'est
développons aujourd'hui 2 une dimension
plus de type biologique la revendication
de l'accès aux souris gilles la place
du député sunnite leurs employés
je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
discours qui tend plutôt à dearborn
est allé trop loin dans la dimension
le pôle vente
volontariste et la filiation dont
prévenant que la même page une
dimension quelque peu le biologique
quand j'essaye de montrer le contraire
et je pense qu'il n'y a pas des liens
plus forts et des liens plus stable et
pour moi c'était bien plus sûre en
tant que joueur histoire et bien d'un
engagement des responsabilités quel est
le lien qui part dès la volonté et non
pas d'une intoxication ou de type
biologique il ajoute que l'évolution
souhaitable qu'est-ce que si on fait
rentrer deux institutions dans le
maine-et-loire
des gens qui n'étaient pas
originairement de loin les juifs
pouvaient pas se marier les protestants
pour ne pas se marier les femmes
étaient soumises aux hommes les enfants
nés hors mariage avait pas de droit
donc tout l'histoire du mariage
l'histoire de l'élargissement des
perquisitions qui atteint de plus qui
n'était pas une fiction explicite
sur le plan du droit
je trouve que l'on est en train de
bouleverser droit de la filiation sans
vraiment le dire
et convaincre faire une impasse
juridique
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de spécialistes
de droit civil et vous avez entendu peu
de spécialistes du droit civil
qui était favorable à ce texte qui les
liait test il a été improvisée
dès l'instant où on touche au coup de
sifflet final placé pour le savoir
parce qu'à l'époque du paf c'était
pareil
on voit que toutes tout ce qu'ils
enseignent le quotidien et tout ce qui
parle du code civil les magistrats les
malfrats de la chancellerie sont
absolument bouleversés et voilà et
puis après il faudrait qu'ils
s'effacent et qui est en fait une de
taille
elle
de ce fait qu'aujourd'hui il ne se
ressent pour l'ensemble des
représentants des cultes
ce triste sort de l'après-midi 14 e +4
au jury le succès des représentants
des grandes religions qui sont
majoritairement contre le projet de loi
le grand rabbin de france gilles
bernheim elle tient un texte qui a
marqué les esprits contre le projet de
loi
je suis sam de la bible
comme peut l'être le chrétien
le musulman l'est aussi mais de manière
différente
puisque le livre
mais paris
pour lui
la bible
lorsqu elles interdisent formellement
l'homosexualité et notamment
expressément le mot s'exécuter
masculine et féminine en parle pas
mais ça c'est un autre sujet
comment est-ce que je me comporte devant
vous avec ce texte
évidemment
avec un tel texte
si vous demandez aucune piste juifs ou
chrétiens
mais
est ce que tu pourquoi ce que tu es
contre le mariage des homosexuels
qu'est-ce qui vous l'éthique qu'ils
amorcent comme réflexion
l'homosexualité étant strictement
interdite dans la bible
il a pu ou ni magie n'est pas un instant
qu'il va vous dire mais le mariage des
homosexuels
et on se mange l'autorisent
mais je vais lui donner
un cadre juridique
j'étais là que la question est
anachronique
là
voilà
première remarque je voudrais faire
face c'est une question
qui peut paraître
de dix centimètres qui ne l'est pas
c'est ce qui si tout le monde
savoir si la différence sexuelle c'est
une inégalité
de la différence sexuelle n'est pas une
inégalité
c'est que les gars d'un vol dans
l'existence humaine
y a des deux nés de fête cette
différence de fête
qui ne donne pas droits juridiques
à devenir comme les autres
cette parcelle le mariage n'est pas
quelques mains publiques qu'on peut
distribuer comme des sucettes à la
sortie de l'école donc ça n'est pas je
sais pas certes pas justice pour injure
que de dire que le mariage
à une fonction elle a une finalité
propre dans la société fier de son
curé d'organiser la transmission entre
les générations l éducation des
enfants il croit youtube m
on ne faisait pas le besoin d'accueillir
plus de fautes que je ne peux plus
personne il peut être consulté
grenoble fait rire c'est ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui
je doute que je prenne ce monsieur me
laisse complètement tranquille
en plus
je veux être plus méchant
plus dur et que rien dans une logique de
commerce qui dit
rien
mais surtout propice le couple
ce que l'on appelle la scène féminine
tout le pays a été adoptée
comme chacun le sait
pour le maire
enfanté dans un sourire
par quels moyens
pm ainsi juste
nous devons le faire
le montrent les auditions d'experts
psychiatres de jéricho
chantal michel relizane ce couple de
retraités après avoir lu leur
témoignage dans un journal
annick il renié et des producteurs de
lait dans la région nantaise
il ya 20 ans ils ont découvert
l'homosexualité de terry la petite
dernière
ils ont fait depuis allouche mines mans
avant de l'accepter
mais le couple marié
je
qui est la quatrième série
de même sexe
dès la 37e
l'affairé
découverte
pays avec le nom de connaissais rien du
tout
un vrai le jouet
derrière
m
fred duban de georges brenier
p
lors des journées
mais je me disais mon enfant et bordeaux
terrible niveau record de mulhouse ce
qu'on voit à la télé nord
donc possible
il était très très dure avec
elle-même une dynamique
curieusement
demain dès maintenant pour vous y
retrouver c'est sûr que quand même eu
un petit coup de vieux bus de nuit
le milieu mais cela n'a pas
il est très dur
depuis inespéré
il est comme
m 37e
et l'arrêté il a été récupéré et
juste
non
d
homosexuelle
ils vivent très bien le rôle
les parents de deux enfants de 9 et 10
mai
l'heureux par m
ce qui
les plus négatifs pour les uns comme
pour les autres
le regard des autres
cinq pays
il n'en est rien
et le regard des autres est parfois
difficile à supporter
deux mois après leur audition au sénat
annick et rené rendu visite à leur
fille eric et à sa compagne b après de
toulouse
au lendemain d'une manifestation des
opposants ils sont inquiets chez la
famille morante par le doute commence à
s'installer ici et si le texte ne
passait pas
cette manifestation tous comme ça on
pousse
c'est aussi fort pour les enfants
comscore
mais c'est faux pourquoi
on peut y voir
c'est assez impressionnant d
j'espère
j'espère que le gouvernement doit
poursuivre
me
même si beaucoup pensent
si aucune victime
certains
a pas grand chose en fait
une société qui est inutile
c'est le temps des choses qui ne servent
en fait de société
pour thierry des débats autour du
projet de loi a fait ressurgir les
fantômes r
complètement renfermée sur la veille
alors dire ça victime
pis même jiji c'était un petit peu
orpheline est conditionné dans un
secteur
c'est pourquoi il vous plaît
il fallait faire
avec l'église avec gdf
pour moi c'était pas compatibles du
tout
demander où ils se trouvent
année portefaix mon frère a été
inscrit
toutefois il ne pourrait pas être trop
connus
comme étant une personne à part
entière
mais je ne suis guère
je me suis mis
enfermé comme
m
parce que j'étais effondré un chic
type
à vous voulez rire
je n'en menais pas large qui conseille
pas quel avec sa voix et sa réaction
j'avais vraiment peur
analyste parisien
reste toujours faire de faute
c'est trop
diana les syndicalistes
pouvoir exprimer
tout ce que j'avais sur le coeur
mais
d'ici le 22
groupe
sur le cas
c'est mal barré les localiser
je lis souvent
mais tous les parents n'acceptent pas
toujours le messti qualité de leurs
enfants
l'association le refuge à paris
héberger des jeunes rejetés par leur
famille
à cause de leur homosexualité
pour le rapporteur du texte au sénat ce
projet de loi à aussi pour but de faire
reculer l'homophobie
la proposition
je verse depuis trois semaines chantal
joue plus depuis quatre ans
nulle part
j'ai été placé en foyer
la rue
l'uci
le troisième set
styliste star c'était l'isaf s'était
pas de domicile
ils font ceux qui acceptent mai
en fait quand ils voyaient musketeers
sénat
c'est une maladie
moi je vienne
quand on vous dit
des citoyens
il peut avoir les mêmes droits que les
autres citoyens
voilà matin
en france elle voulait fonder une morale
eric woerth
oui
chantrapas qu'ils ont fait l'objet d'un
rejet familial
je pense que ce qu'il faut dire
faux il raconte que des philippins
je crois que
quelles que puissent être
et déception qu'on peut avoir
elle vous en france au portugal
je peux comprendre
je ne pense pas qu'il faut voter
l'égypte
je suis là au sénat jean-pierre michel
retrouve les députés hier la guinée
rapporteur de la loi à l'assemblée
nationale populaire gérard points
l'objectif examiner le texte dans le
détail afin de pointer du doigt les
améliorations que le sénat pourrait
apporter par rapport à la version de
l'assemblée nationale
après avoir examiné le texte
détaillé
il a paré et puis avoir entendu à sa
proposition
elle lui apparaît et que
mais c'est valable pour apporter à cet
amendement
j'aime bien ce moment parce que pour
faire de son passage dans le dos
on confie le sénat
pour l'instant
dans le temps avec la vente
qui
défendre les enfants alors que j'ai
déposé
ou que le gel des pensions de mère
indigne
pour le savoir
et puis peut-être le disputer
sur quelques points techniques mineurs
ont été révélées par ces
tardivement ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
le débat l'assemblée a été quand
même très très difficile qui triture
le lien unique d'insertion
d'improvisation en sciences d'ailleurs
le gouvernement lui-même dit claude
certaine
chose qui a été adoptée de mérite
d'être mieux
crozier
le rapporteur du texte au sénat
souhaite modifier la version de
l'assemblée nationale ceux des points
juridiques à la marge
mes chers collègues
nous allons découvrir eux notre cette
séance
je vous remercie d'être venus de très
nombreux signe de l'intérêt et qui est
le vôtre pour le texte sur le mariage
pour tous
esthétique italease de plus les
tensions chez les sénateurs alors qu'il
s'interroge la ministre sur son projet
de loi
c'est la question de la filiation et de
la pma alors merci madame belles passes
d'armes s'il le souhaite
des sources pour quelle raison a
également sur
la pma et la gpa
qui sont impossibles ce qui fait de ce
sera une autre chanteuse rose
élisa de 114 the dirty penser toujours
n'en parler jamais donc ce qui me gêne
beaucoup si vous voulez ce qui fait tout
moi je suis de ceux qui de nombreux la
vraie morale ou aux plumes
hostilité de rencontre
à harrous mariage entre personnes du
même sexe mais il me semble que si
j'accepte à la fois le mariage et
l'adoption inéluctablement chollon
effectivement d ddd autorité en
matière juridique d'autant danses
différentes je serai amené à accepter
la pma la gpa
partout c'est un peu confidences
c'est à dire une certaine forme de
marchandisation des corps toujours au
fuse alors comment peut-on faire de
même et ce pour tous
cet engrenage se mettent pas en route
pour répondre à votre question sur
l'engrenage
il ya des traitements différenciés
entre l'assistance médicale à la
procréation et la gestation pour autrui
à partir du moment où la gestation
pour autrui c'est la position du maire
très claire très fier demeure
imprécis
de belles disponibilité du corps ils
ont d'ores publique
e c'est le barrage à l'engrenage c'est
le barrage avant
m
pourquoi
l'émissaire collègues
nous sommes sommes satisfaits à notre
dernière audition publique
et je peux vous dire c'est que peu de le
pousser cette dernière condition
2 une occasion pour moi de vous dire
combien nous avons pris plaisir à
toutes ses auditions en tout cas plaisir
intellectuel
et combien suzhou dussions-nous sombre
apporter
au terme des auditions
le collectif la manif pour tous amenés
par frigide par jour demandé à être
entendu à son tour
mais jean-pierre michel refuse de les
recevoir
c'est avant tout une question de temps
ma qualité
demandes les plus grands comme pour les
autres
deuxième raison c'est que dans le fond
je considère que cette
ceux d'autres nations je suis de toutes
pièces pour les besoins de la cause
lorraine un portefeuille
d'autant plus une partie sérieuse
et que donc
on peut pas se cacher
au surplus qui veut dire que
les manifestations auxquelles ce qu'il
faut organiser et mener 5-1
mb
choquée
un certain nombre de termes qui ont
été employés par
christelle d'homophobie attentes on peut
dire son nom mais qui existe
pour motiver son refus d'après michel
écrit une lettre au collectif la manif
pour tous
sarkozy et du sénateur gibbs a assuré
le collectif ils n'ont aucune
légitimité
pour
sa lettre il amène au cours de
l'automne
le parquet a décidé à la retraite de
jean-pierre michel en était besoin
c'est michel
n'avait pas envoyé cette lettre infra
menthe voilà et diffamatoire
et dans ce cas-là ci-dessus lors des
questions au gouvernement il a pris part
un poster cette loi excessive
nous ne sommes pas dans la rue
brigitte bardot et la manif pour tous se
réclament 6000 euros de dommages et
intérêts
finalement le tribunal déboute les
requérants
or
elle
pendant ce temps le sénat avant les
examens en séance publique
la commission des lois examine le
rapport de jean-pierre michel
le texte est adopté avec deux pointes
de l'opposition
ce débat il n'a pas été un débat
nous les joueurs
entreprises seulement par rapport à
leur poids
appartenance
ce n'est pas son secret
club de ski
b l'équipement le texte
et comme deux cellules
pratique bush
mais bon pas pris part au vote
une évolution de mettre en oeuvre le
savait
1 la magistrat au restaurant où il se
trouve que j'ai retenue la meilleure
voie est celle qui entérine
l'évolution des moeurs
on peut pas aujourd'hui accepter de dire
rien ne s'est passé on est obligé de
l'accepter et donc il faut que la loi
soit
et en plus la france n'est pas seule
dans le monde
il est obligé de tenir compte autant
les pochettes surprises mais elle ne
peut pas ne pas en tenir compte
mais la mobilisation des opposants au
projet de loi ne faiblit pas
dans les divines julien et cécile se
prépare pour une nouvelle manifestation
cette foire du nord mène le radar
dans les rivières et autres
et william
l'homosexualité pour manier
mais talent n'est pas plus hautes
instances du débat en fait je pense que
l'homosexualité assez
entre de l'insee peut dire c'est que
c'est l'application en forêt en fait je
pense que tout le débat qui est rentré
en jeu passe dans son projet de loi
c'est tout ce qui concerne les relations
et social appelé amin et que pourquoi
pour patrick chêne des marais pour eux
d'y renoncer alors on pense notamment
aux mots formidable outil notamment la
seine en face à xerez en fait ça ça
va dans les deux sens
il n'est que par la volonté des états
membres comme ça comme ça on parle
passe pour les petits pas
outre ceux des tca un peu de temps à
perdre de rance
et je pense que c'est la seule façon de
ne pas répondre c'est vraiment une
négation de la démocratie
m
gémeauxvous payer le terrain
sur le fond coc
toujours est-il que personne ne sait
pourquoi
m
elle
à croire elle
pourquoi
le journal d'opposition etemad
la manifestation va s'est terminée par
des affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre
et des gaz lacrymogènes
le collectif la manif pour tous va se
laisser déborder par des éléments
plus radicaux
la contestation s'est durci
les agressions homophobes se multiplient
et le sénat a entamé l'examen du texte
jean-pierre michel reste serein et
déterminé
dans l'état d'esprit des mesures
concrètes afin de convaincre
on est aux environs de la commission le
fairmont rapport et puis après
la nuit d'avant s'est déroulé pendant
quelques jours au sénat et je suis
très heureux d'arriver à ce stade la
procédure j'allais dire voilà
la séance de reprise de l'ordre du jour
de la discussion du projet de loi
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
ouvrant le mariage aux couples de
personnes de même sexe
dans la discussion générale la parole
quand madame christiane taubira garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
la garde des sceaux qui vient défendre
le texte du gouvernement devant les
sénateurs
comme à son habitude elle va prononcer
un discours son acte pendant 40 minutes
cette institution du mariage
qui ya été une restitution de la
propriété autant au mali a sur tous
les patrimoines
ainsi qu'une institution de domination
guitar pro la mémoire ordonné en
décembre avec 12
lady gaga est une institution
dad aussi sûrement que du mari sur les
phares sur la femme et sur les enfants
quels étaient les institutions
d'exclusion d'exclusion sur la base de
la religion d'exclusion sur la base de
la profession description sur la base
d'éléments pour alliance
cette institution est en train de
devenir universel sur ce projet de loi
nous avons peu de points d'accord
mais nous en avons 1
il n'est pas anecdotique il est même l
essentiel
et comme vous l'avez si bien indiqué
cette réforme
et pour frais manger une réforme de
civilisation
c'est aussi ce point de consensus
pardonnerez
qui va finalement nous opposer de toute
la force
de nos convictions et elles ne sont pas
tiède
ni les votre
ni les nôtres
nous partageons c'est vrai cette idée
est qu'avec ce texte
il y a un basculement vous soutenez que
c'est un progrès
nous pensons que les péruviens
vous avez commencé par rappeler un
argument qui a été pour beaucoup
utilisé et puis il a fini par tomber un
plan d'ici l'étudiant lui dire
à l'assemblée nationale aussi
sur la réforme de civilisation
je me réfère à la civilisation
au sens où et le nécessaire
elle dit
une civilisation qui ruse avec ses
principes
c'est une civilisation moribonde
et je reprends donc cette définition la
france oui la france
s'est construite a construit la nation
de la république c'était république
sur la passion de l'égalité sur la
passion de l'égalité et on windows
réclamant de l'égalité
parce que reste-t-il alors fondamentales
de la république et que c'est la marque
particulière
dans l'histoire de la nation française
et dans l'histoire de la république
française oui mais non comme on aurait
faire à cette égalité
à ce stade nous référant à cette
valeur
donc on s'attend effectivement à
diverses périodes il a en réserve avec
l'égalité
créteil xte on a parfois été
maladroits
voici soeur des citoyens
la plénitude de l'exercice de la
citoyenneté
et c'est ça que nous corrigions
laurent
de nombreux représentants des
différentes villes du pays m
le gouvernement plus de détails dans le
monde
m
elle
alors que l'été n'a pas entrer dans le
vif du sujet
les pro et les anti font monter la
pression aux abords du palais du luxe
oui
aïe
la ville
barre
à ce moment rasmussen
à tout cela 10h30 en plus ici place à
prendre quotidiennement pendant sept
jours les opposants ont manifesté pour
porter du sénat
pour coups et blessures
encore
la construction
pratiquer le prendrons
yann thomas enders quand on est jeune on
peut entendre la très sainte vierge
marie
bien vouloir orienté le choix pour ça
qu'il soit bon c'est à dire contre le
projet du mariage homosexuel
moi aussi
l'or
et pour cause
%
le porter
il pourrait
alors
pour ce faire
la zakat pas tardé nous ne nous
rendrons
mais
voir
le réparer
dans l'ensemble la santé
on veut se prendre la tête
en l'absence du buteur sur le fond des
choses
je crois que
il ya un vrai pays ce qui signifie et
c'est une autre forme de violence que de
changer
le sens des mots
vous changez d'abord le sens des mots
sur le plan sémantiquement
dans le français aujourd'hui selon
l'académie française
le mariage
l union légitime d'un homme et d'une
femme
vous changer les mots le sens des mots
je peux vous dire que toutes les
sciences humaines et sociales
montre bien entendu le contraire et
quant au prix de l'académie française
elle même parce que si les mots
n'avaient qu'à un sens et que ce sens
été tués il nous le rappelle
là ce serait contraire à l'histoire
des langages l'histoire tout court vous
savez que le dictionnaire de l'académie
française le plus récent
monsieur le premier ministre c'est le 9e
le premier date de 1694
si on a fait une oeuvre dictionnaire de
l'académie française c'est que le sens
de beaucoup de mots échangés
les mots sont des êtres vivants oui
s'il vient de trancher dans la mesure
où cette question d'un jour conviction
c'est un texte qui reprend gage beaucoup
plus que ce que nous sommes parce que
oui
de bp je crois que c'est aussi le
message qu'ont beaucoup des livres et
les millions de français qui ont vu
défiler depuis des mois et des mois ce
n'est pas plus texas et le kennedy de
ton côté droit autre équipe pour eux
on se bat aussi pour les français de
demain c'est-à-dire pour les nouvelles
générations je suis favorable à ce
texte à ce que je considère que mon
père
examen de la loi se poursuit avec
l'adoption de l'article 1er
qui institue que le mariage est ouverte
aux couples de même sexe
les sénateurs de l'ump et ont longtemps
bataillé pour plutôt offrir une union
civile en couples homosexuels un
amendement présenté par le doyen
gélard qui est finalement rejetée d'un
revers de la main la pression monte les
quelques élus de droite qui ont
déclaré publiquement voté en faveur
du texte
reçoivent des insultes et des lettres
anonymes
certains sont même dérangé chez eux
au petit matin
c'est pas la violence qui détermine un
pote sont des valeurs que des
convictions
et que le débat est effectif 6 donc qui
manifestent ici c'est normal les
institutions démocratiques c'est ici
mais pourquoi justement on se réclame
de la défense des droits de la famille
il faut éviter de la durée
jean-pierre michel et lui aussi la cible
des opposants au mariage homosexuel
chaque jour il reçoit des dizaines de
courriers
reconnaître l'une des cartes postales
aussi
donc c'est très bien ça adonne bureau
de la poste
% quelles sont envoyés
elle et qu'elle décerne le prix staline
2013 de la tolérance
donc que cette dans le recrutement
voilà on dit que
j'ai dit que l'année passée au naturel
je pense
ce que la loi c'est le rapport de force
entre un moment donné on le voit
des majorités parlementaires qui se
créent et qui font la loi après sa 4
fois le loyer et deux nuls et défaites
pas toutes ça arrive
et que les rapports de force politiques
un certain moment donné et que ses
rapports de force
eh bien il en sort du bois y compris
dans la société piquante mais voilà
à
m
woerth
maire
ailleurs elle est rétrograde d'un
côté
les progressistes de l'eau
vous avez d'un côté
l'idée est d'une famille idéal
une famille idéal
un papa une maman
deux enfants
cf j'ai envie de vous dire d'abord
est-ce que cette famille idéale exister
une seule fois
dans l'histoire
et ensuite même si cette famille des
halles existent
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la société
et le fait
que ça vous plaise que ça vous plaise
pas et que ça me plaise que ça ne
m'intéresse pas
et cette diversité
forme de famille
vous pouvez proposer effectivement une
famille idéale
et que moi j'ai envie de vous opposer
la diversité des familles réelle
existantes aujourd'hui
jean-pierre michel profite d'une
suspension de séance pour aller à la
rencontre des partisans
un projet de loi m
pour les banques
soit
aujourd'hui
p mais c'est en train de changer d'avis
franchement g
la future maman oui
à l'heure des repas à aire
l'événement de cette rentrée
merci merci mille fois
encore
pourquoi en france
au retour des vestiaires
elle
pourquoi
les amendements dans les mythiques
la pression des anti ne se relâche pas
jusque tard dans la nuit ils
continuaient à manifester leur
opposition devant les grilles du palais
du luxembourg
ça
voir le temps
le peuple français
indépendamment
ces institutions
du parlement qui sur ce sujet
ne représentent pas l'opinion
tusk
mes chers collègues
je ne veux voir l'ensemble
du projet de loi ouvrant le mariage aux
couples de personnes de même sexe
ceux qui sont favorables pour remonter
la blonde
merci ceux qui sont encore en cours
merci abstention
mes chers collègues le sénat adoptée
le projet de loi
avant le mariage
beaucoup de personnes
de même sexe
finalement après sept jours de débats
le sénat a voté le texte à main
levée aucun groupe politique ayant
demandé un scrutin public
la loi a été adopté par 171 voix
contre 165
le mans
les compresseurs
gouvernement pour la qualité de vos
interventions
pour des bottes je veux croire au nord
le sud
ci-dessus
le rapporteur de la commission des lois
merci monsieur le président mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues
bien sûr vous le comprendrez tout avec
beaucoup de fierté et d'émotion
donc je savoure ce moment kazan après
l'adoption du pacte
de faire en sorte que je participe à
une histoire qui n'est pas fini pour les
tout-petits non l'histoire n'est pas
finie elle se poursuivra par des
améliorations constantes parce que ces
salauds de société
nos enfants la sitution à en
républicaine du mariage aux couples de
même sexe
la force et la puissance de la loi
consiste à énoncer des règles
générales
qui puisse couvrir toute la diversité
des situations
eyi anticiper sur la pompe l'excité des
litiges
et nous savons
à quel point l'imagination des hommes
et des femmes est infinie
pauvre compliqué les litiges notamment
parce que la dsi par action
en cas de conflit
le juge interviendra
le juge interviendra pour protéger
le membre du couple au-delà familles
les plus vulnérables plus fragiles il
interviendra pour veiller à à la
terrasse
des enfants
et je parle d'enfants oui je parle
d'enfants mais dans ce temps d'enfants
ils vivent et qui existe de 16 enfants
qui sont dans cette famille
de ces enfants qui sont faites de chair
et d'os
quittons nous ressentons vibrant de tri
de rire
de ces enfants qui sépare ce genou de
ces entretiens mais ces prairies qui
n'est pas célèbre paul ii de ces
enfants qui nous expose la tête la
saison en formula ce sont telles que
vous protéger
avec ce texte de loi
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que l'om
on met des bataillons c'est quand même
triste mémoire
on sait qu'on résiste
cet article
et puis en mai c'est fait ce monde
sur place actuellement
ce comité sera également concernée
personne
face à la radicalisation des opposants
le gouvernement décide d'accélérer le
rythme
le texte est inscrit à l'ordre du jour
de l'assemblée nationale dès la
semaine suivante
la loi est adopté conforme
c'est-à-dire sans modification par les
députés
le 23 avril 2013
la procédure parlementaire
arrivé à son terme
r non
pour ce
après
après l'entreprise
et 40 plus mais les deux départs
l'assemblée nationale
a adopté le projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage
en couple de personnes de même sexe
les droits de nos concitoyens
dans la citoyenneté été sournoisement
contestées et nous avons ouvert des
droits
tous les autres couples c'est donc un
contest ablement un texte généreux que
vous avez vous souhaitez
mais l'opposition n'entend pas en rester
là
elle saisit le conseil constitutionnel
pour tenter d'invalider le texte
finalement les sages de la rue de
montpensier donnent leur feu vert
la loi est promulguée dans la foulée
par le président de la république
quelques jours plus tard à montpellier
bruno évinçant se disent oui devant
les caméras du monde entier
ce
voir
pourquoi
la france
déjà le quatorzième pays au monde à
l'autorité le mariage homosexuel